bonjour arnaud benedetti merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france que
pensez-vous de cette initiative du
gouvernement
elle traduit surtout un contexte où le
gouvernement et l'exécutif sont en
difficulté avec l'opinion suite à une
communication suite à une parole
publique qui aujourd'hui est mise en
doute par un certain nombre à la fois
d'observateurs de médias et puis par une
grande partie de l'opinion publique
quand on regarde les études d'opinion
maintenant qui se succèdent depuis le
début de cette crise on voit que un
sentiment de défiance soutenue s'est
installé dans l'opinion publique et
vraisemblablement à travers cette
initiative assez étrange l'exécutif
pense pour graver d'une certaine manière
contrecarrer les mauvais effets qui ont
été produits par sa communication dans
quelle mesure les fêtes news constitue
un véritable problème depuis le début de
l'épidémie
écoutez un exécutif de toute façon
depuis 2017 a fait de la lutte contre
l'effet que nous qui ne sont rien
d'autre qu'une des figures parmi
d'autres de la désinformation l'un de
ses objectifs considérant que en effet
ce phénomène mené profondément vicié le
débat public et surtout déstabilisé
l'expression publique du gouvernement
aujourd'hui ce que l'on voit
dans cette crise c'est que le fait que
la parole publique a manqué de clarté a
manqué de transparence a certainement
susciter disons non seulement des doutes
et parfois des informations certainement
tronquées ou des contenus tronqué sur
les réseaux mais il est clair que
lorsque un exécutif veut communiquer
avec son opinion il faut que lui même
cuisse est rivé trop châble et force est
de constater que ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui de l'exécutif depuis le
début de cette pandémie la polémique sur
les masques en étant à mon sens
l'illustration la plus incandescente
est ce que quelque part on en met
justement vous poser la question de la
crédibilité du gouvernement de cette
plateforme puisque elle eu des
maladresses sur en fugue ans à la
communication gouvernementale sur les
masques est ce que pour est-ce que c'est
justifié aujourd'hui pour le
gouvernement est ce que c'est une action
à son avantage finalement d'installer
cette plate forme aujourd'hui
mais de toute façon ce n'est pas un
exécutif dans une démocratie libérale
c'est à dire dans une démocratie
pluraliste où la liberté de la presse
est une condition de l'exercice
démocratique de nous dire la façon dont
nous devons lire la presse et de
sélectionner ceux qui à ses yeux
constitue la bonne ou la mauvaise
information c'est une interprétation
tout à fait particulière du
fonctionnement d'une démocratie libérale
une démocratie libérale par essence est
par construction
il faut qu'elle laisse l'espace public
débattre et c'est à l'intérieur de
l'espace public que les organes de
presse que les journalistes qui sont les
mieux placés pour nous dire si une
information est validée ou ne l'est pas
en l'occurrence la l'état s'arroge une
mission qui n'est pas la sienne
et c'est vrai que c'est assez surprenant
que l'on puisse avoir dans une
démocratie comme la nôtre un exécutif
qui viennent nous dire quels sont les
bons titres de presse quels sont ceux
qui ne le sont pas quelle est la bonne
information
l'état n'a pas à jouer le rôle de
certificateur de la formation ça va
créer vous pensez un fossé
entre d'une part le gouvernement et les
médias ou pas mais ça traduit évidemment
une défiance non seulement vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique qu'on considère comme
une oubliée public qui ne seraient pas
suffisamment mûr pour elle-même
décrypter les contenus qu'elle a à lire
et ça traduit évidemment aussi une
défiance vis-à-vis de la presse si
l'avis d'une presse pluraliste mais
petit fait son travail dans un contexte
d'être été très difficile et ça induit
soupçons quand même sur la façon dont
l'exécutif gère sa relation avec la
presse
merci beaucoup arnaud benedetti je
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire
merci à vous